[Music]
let's go to leslie in richmond
virginia what's up leslie
thank you so much john i understand
there's allergies we've got those here
too everybody's got it i'm i'm hoping
that's what it is yeah so i i i
it makes me sound i don't know like
cooler more wise like i'm tough i don't
know i i
imagine listen to you absolutely thank
you for giving me that list
hey so what's up how can i
well first of all thank you so much for
your program i started listening several
months ago and i started from the first
episode i've made it to january 2021 so
i have learned so much and thank you so
much
hey so i haven't done that in fact i've
listened to a grand total of none of
these shows
is it getting better that might be for
the best is it getting better it is oh
and remarkably remarkably i have noticed
so much i mean it started out great and
it has just done nothing but improved it
was pretty wobbly it was not great i
mean i used to watch james went home he
was on a lot he was just taking tums by
the i mean it was tough and
kelly was drinking i mean not drink a
lot she wasn't drinking a lot i'm just
she wasn't she wasn't i told her i
wouldn't make that joke anymore i got a
coffee a lot a lot of coffee
and um
and creatine and other positive
supplements protein shakes things like
that but anyway thank you so much
i appreciate that all right so how can i
help
i've got a lot going on um in my life
right now i'm in my mid 50s and um had
some issues with my both of my grown
sons but the um thing that i'm calling
about today is our 26 year old son told
us last summer that he's been taking
female hormones for two years
he said that he wants us to call him
rachel okay and then about a month later
he moved to houston to live with his
partner who is also a trans woman okay
about once a week i text him just to
make sure he's okay and he texts back
but other than i'll call it christmas we
haven't spoken okay um my husband and i
have made plans
to visit him in late june
we told him that we have no agenda but
that we love him and we miss him okay
my question is
how do we deal excuse me
now take your time take your time
yeah how do we deal with the name
pronoun issue if calling him rachel and
using feminine pronouns
compromises our values
then how do we open the line of
communication with him and build our
relationship
uh this is yeah so one thank you for
your trust this one's this one's hard
um
it is uh
so
let me back out a little bit um
tell me why over the last year or so or
let me ask you before that was this is
total shock to you a surprise to you he
how would you say he was
26 26 okay okay so he had he had moved
out to go to college and that didn't go
well but he was living with the um
roommate what is not what does not go
well what does not go well mean that he
didn't do well in college he's um
academically social
but academically academically mainly
okay um but it's because
i'm i'm not really sure the issue what
the issue is there because he's super
smart he um he could tell you just about
any line in the narnia series i mean
he's just super super smart
but um
so that tell so having worked with
college students for the major vast
majority of my career
i ran into that a lot and that suggests
there were other things going on in in
his life
or in her life
um
so as far as going back to whether it
was a shock to us
being a trans woman was a shock to us we
suspected there were things going on and
i suspected even though he'd had a
girlfriend for six years
when he broke up with her
um
i really strongly started suspecting
that he was having
um you know i don't know just you know i
just figured there was something going
on but i didn't know that it was the
trans woman i had no clue so that hit us
out of the blue so i i don't know gloss
over did you think i i've got inklings
that my son's gay
right yeah okay all right his roommate
his roommate seemed gay but um i they
didn't seem to be in a relationship i
mean he called me from two hours away to
come get him when he had kidney stones
instead of asking his roommate to take
him to the hospital
so i didn't really see them in a
relationship but i could tell that he
was very feminine yeah
well i
um
so i've got a number of gay friends that
i'm not in a relationship with so just
just right just being in proximity
doesn't doesn't mean anything
um all right and that's how i saw it at
the time yeah i
um
here's what i'm asking i i've had this
conversation i can't count the number of
parents i've sat down i had this
conversation with and it's not it's not
rare it's rather common not always but
rather common what you just said i
felt that my son was or or daughter was
struggling
was having some identity like
questioning who they were and what they
were um and well
so there's there's a lot of layers to
this and so i'm gonna walk through it
backwards forwards okay and we'll get
i'll get to your to your your final
question here but i want to address you
and your husband along the way here
right thank you the guilt
and the
regardless of what the outcome is
whether it's an uh
an outcome that you have a agreement
with alignment with value with whatever
there's i've never yet that's not true
i've met a couple and they're jerks i've
never met parents or rarely met parents
who don't feel guilt along the way that
i can't believe my kid was wrestling
with something so heavy and i i wasn't
there to walk alongside him right
and it's it's that it's a parents bang
their head against the wall and they
feel deep shame and often the result the
actions that come next come out of that
shame and i should have been there and i
can't believe my kid was hurting like
that all alone and fill in the blank
and whether you agree with the pronouns
or the anything you agree with that or
not everybody can agree that kids that
are are wrestling with gender identity
am i a man am i a woman who am i going
to be who am i going to love
that they are really going through a
hard hard time like there's elevated
suicide arrests elevated mental health
challenges
devastating time
and so as a parent
gosh i wish i'd been there right so it's
important for you to own that and it's
going to be real important when you
re-engage with your child okay
okay um
that you come to the table with
with
here's what i'm feeling and we should
have been there for you i'm sorry right
there's that sense of whether you like
should or shouldn't have been he also or
she also had was an adult and could have
had to come back right he had a
responsibility to talk to you it is what
it is
i think it's important to be open with
how you feel so then um they moved to
houston
and they've got a relationship why have
you just texted what is waiting what has
taken you so long
to engage
right well we text about once a week
because i just need to know that he's
okay but why haven't you got on a plane
and come in and and
looked your child in the eye and said i
love you um
right um
well my my job makes it so it's easier
for me to go
once
when i have a break
so
it'll be easier for me to go now but i
don't know why i have no answer for why
i didn't go
earlier
um i've been wrestling with so many
things but um i don't think that we've
ever well i can honestly say we've never
had good communication in our home
with any of us we're not good at
communicating we're great communicators
but not together
and that's what i have seen
when i've evaluated the past
and that's what i'm trying to fix with
both of my children
so
i'm gonna be pretty direct with you is
that okay
okay that's okay
i don't care about your job
and i don't care about how easy your job
it was it's easier on a break or
whatever
right exactly your child came to you and
said
mom i'm hurting
and you've spent the last six months
texting
and so
that's one of those moments
not to change the outcome not to what
there's not an roi on this
right there is a you're my baby
right and i know you're hurting
and i know you've been sitting here
right after we found out he came and
spent a week with us okay before he
moved to texas and how did that go
it went it was like normal we didn't he
didn't seem feminine and it was so
normal and we had kind of normal
interactions we fell into our same
routine
i had one talk with him that was
um that
that was very a very good talk with him
that was positive mostly positive 90
positive okay with him during that week
but because we just don't have good
communication
hey listen listen
you are the parent
right good
starts with you
right and so it's not this amorphous
thing that we just don't have like money
like we just don't have money right yeah
good communication is a choice
okay so i haven't learned how to have a
good conversation with my children okay
here's where that starts and ends with i
love you
and i'm so glad you're my child
full stop period at the end of that
sentence and then we're just gonna hug
for a while
that's where it starts
there's not a sophisticated entry
there's not a
there's not a it doesn't need to have
like a
like a
bunch of check boxes it starts with i
love you and you're my kid
i can do that
and there will come seasons when they'll
look at you and say why now
what happened at 14 and what happened at
18 and there's gonna be some guilt there
and there's gonna be some shame there's
gonna be some frustration there and what
you'll have to do is own what happened
it is and you'll have to look at your
kids and say i was the adult
and i didn't have good communication and
i'm sorry
and what i can only think i can do now
is get better moving forward
that's i mean that's your choice or the
other choice is just to continue to walk
and go we just don't have good
communication in our house
we just don't have it yeah yeah
no i don't i don't i don't want to do
that
so
jump in with both feet
okay okay
and
don't let me say it this way don't over
complicate it
okay don't over complicate it
um that's good for me to hear because i
do that yeah don't
and
let you here's where you are now now
you're at a place where you need to be
super super super honest
i put my job before this relationship
or i waited for things to get convenient
and quite honestly i was scared because
i didn't know how to do it and i'm sorry
yeah that's it that's it and so listen
they have felt that for 26 years your
kids right right they felt the gap they
felt that's more important or this is
more important or
the not feeling uncomfortable having a
conversation with us was more important
than having a conversation with us
they've felt that gap and they've spent
their entire life trying to bridge that
gap or figure it out or just completely
disconnect from it
and so
most
it took a close friend of mine sitting
down with me and this is probably 15 or
20 years ago
and walked me through
how heavy
a coming out narrative is
right the phone call
was probably weeks or months if not
years in the making and it was
really hard to do
even if you get that right so so here
was like
the back end of that is i'm getting on a
plane
i'm putting you on a plane
right and
early on he shared some reading material
with me and i read through everything he
said that's fine that's fine so okay so
let's get to the let's get to the
okay see here's the thing you don't need
more data right now you need
relationships exactly you don't need
more info there's not a thing he's going
to tell you and you're going to go oh
okay right and vice versa
there's not an argument you're going to
give him and he's going to be like you
know what i've i didn't know that that's
not the way this is going to play out
right exactly okay
he needs his mom
right or she needs her mom like what
whatever pronoun y'all decide to use so
let's go there here here's the deal
your child has put a boundary down
and said
this is
me right now and this is me moving
forward
you have your values
and what you have to decide
is my relationship with my child
more or less important than a previously
established value
that's the conversation to have
what you can't do
is say
um we won't have a relationship with you
on our terms
because
or she has told you what their terms are
and that's the hard part you find
yourself in
well part of the struggle has been this
whole feeling like i don't know this
person he wants to be called rachel i
don't know this person rachel
rachel
you know it feels like he killed like
rachel killed my son yeah
so and here's here's the other side of
this conversation that never gets
brought up
you're allowed to feel that way
right and you're allowed to feel sad and
you're allowed to have had plans and
pictures of grandkids in your head and
what thanksgivings are going to look
like in years and now that picture is
very very different you're allowed to
grieve that too
and that's left out of the conversation
um
what you're what you're allowed to do
whatever you want to do because you're
an adult
right the fewer secrets the better
for everybody
right
and
um you're right
you don't know your child
you don't
and it's probably been that way for a
long long time you had a an image of
your child that you that you thought you
knew him right and i would say even
if he wasn't uh or she wasn't choosing
to change their gender
um
you still wouldn't know your child you
would have a you know
you
your
rachel could still still be dan and have
a wife and five kids
and you would not know your child
and maybe that's the entry point i love
you
and i don't know you
and i want to get to know you because i
love you okay
and
you will have to decide
and every family's got to make these
choices and i'm not going to let i'm not
going to give you a pass and give do it
for you
you've got to choose
are we going to have a relationship with
our child or not
right and if we are
then my child has established some
boundaries
and some expectations and we have to
decide whether we're going to meet those
or not
and here let's let's take let's take the
the transgender thing the the because
that's the third real issue let's take
that move it away
this happened with if you're going to
come to my house you have to wear a mask
be on my kids
or
you can't wear a mask in my home i don't
want my kids seeing that kind of stuff
or you have to be vaccinated or you
can't drink or
you can't come the day before christmas
because we're going somewhere
children put down boundaries and then
parents have to say these are our values
are we going to
expand shift change modulate out of or
double down on
our previous values
or are we going to double down our
relationship
i hear you that makes sense
yeah it makes sense it makes a lot of
sense
how much of this
is about
your child
how much of this is about being caught
off guard
and how much of this is about how am i
going to tell my friends
and my faith community and my
whatever because a lot of times i hear
it's about embarrassment
right well initially there was some of
that but i have some experience in a
counseling field and so
um
i
i'm very open with people okay i am more
so than my husband is
um
i would go and i would you know i would
go and tell everybody just because this
might help you that's how i am i'll tell
you my experience because it might help
you okay and my husband is nobody needs
to know our business okay that's that's
fair my house is very similar to that
um yeah
so
to simplify everything
your child has said
this is where i'm at
and do you love me
and you have an answer
you have a choice to make
right
and it may be that
um your answer is different than your
husband's answer
it may be that y'all's answer is
together it may be your answer is we are
going to
double down a relationship first and
engage in a series of conversations over
the next few years but the conversations
aren't debates or discussions or
whatever the debates are the the
conversations are someone get to know
you
right and that's what i want yeah so
that's that's where i'd start that's a
humble
um
control alt delete place to start
all right
and as far as something i've been
wondering as i've been listening through
your program and you talk about i don't
know if you're still talking about it
but in the part that i've listened
you've talked a lot about having like a
formal funeral or something like that so
i wondered if i should
if if that would be helpful i thought
about it a little bit
if you're there i mean if that if that's
where this ultimately ends up i think
it's always good
you know yeah i i wouldn't have a
funeral
of your child yeah because your child is
still fully alive um right
but not i mean about that dream that i
had of the person i thought he was going
to be it's important to acknowledge i
had this picture of my head
not that he or she created but that you
created
and you put expectations into the world
that your child was going to fulfill
that they are under no obligation to
fulfill and every parent on planet earth
does this by the way you're not the only
one oh yeah you know what i mean oh yeah
and so
um something as little in my home is i
just always played baseball and my dad
always played baseball and my son was
awesome at baseball and then he came to
us over the holidays and said hey
um
would it be cool if i didn't play
baseball and instead i did theater
i did theater too i did in college i
loved it and
i just had a picture of my kid playing
baseball all the way through
and so i didn't have a big funeral i
didn't have a bit but i had to stop and
go yeah of course you can man and i was
really proud of him for having that
conversation with us and coming to us
with it and um
communication is a big deal in our house
and so i'm so proud of him for doing
that because i know that was hard for
him and
i had to go
i kind of had pictures i don't know
where they came from i just had pictures
of us going to high school baseball
games and we're not going to do that
and so yeah it's important to hold that
i wouldn't have a funeral for your child
um right i mean i guess i've thought of
that because it has felt so much it
feels like a death right but i know it's
a death of a dream that i have it's
grief yes
and you're allowed to grieve and anybody
that tells you otherwise is is
not being honest with you you're allowed
to say i hoped or had pictures of this
and something else is happening you can
also grieve how much pain your kid's
been in for a long time
because whether you believe with the in
the outcome and that's a whole other
conversation if you believe and
transgender this and that's a whole
other
everybody can agree your kid's been
hurting for a long time
it sounds like both your son's been hurt
for a long time and given your
like your honesty about how you struggle
with communication and how work comes
first and then when it's convenient
we'll pay
it's time you start and say i'm sorry
and i'm ready to do this thing
from the floor up
and i'm going to grieve what we lost
together i'm going to agree that i
wasn't there for you when you were
hurting
and now i'm going to do the best i can
to walk alongside you whatever that
looks like or you can choose no
you can choose hey if this is what you
need and as the person you're choosing
to become
your dad and i are opting out
that's your choice
people ask me um my opinion on stuff and
i tell them what i would do
and i'll tell you i'm gonna choose
relationship with my kids every time